hello everyone it's me again with some
good news and
good moves it's magnus carlson versus
daniel dubose and they are in the tie
breaks they will play two blitz match
blitz games and then if we don't have a
a winner after those two blitz games
have been played then we go into
armageddon so first game already a crazy
one now let's check it out
this is even faster this is five plus
three so now let's see what happened the
magnus with the white pieces
opens with e4 sorry about that
uh and they repeat a line from uh from
the
rapid part of the match with e5 knight
f3 knight to c6
and bishop to c4 dubo goes for the two
knights defense like he already did
d3 and h6 now we have knight to c3 and
then
bishop to b4 so uh we've already seen
this we have castles
and now captures in c3 b captures and
castles by duba and this bishop to b3
move by magnus however
in that game you remember dugo played
first d6 and then he wasted the temple
by playing d5 but
here he goes d5 right away so even
though bishop to b3 is a newly in the
position it's actually as we already
know they played this
d5 is the new move in the position so
already as of move eight a completely
new game
uh we have e captures and e5 knight
characters and
now h3 already uh an imprecision by
magnus rook to e1
is what you would one should play here
but then you kind of allow bishop to g4
and none of it
really looks appealing so here h3 was
played by magnus
but now comes knight captures on c3 uh
magnus of course gives up this pawn to
go for queen to e1 now with the double
attack on the knight
and on the pawn and now comes knight the
d4 by duval
a very very tricky idea of course the
knight cannot be captured if you capture
the knight
knight to e2 check with a nice royal
fork so
instead of that magnus goes after the e5
pawn knight captures an e5 and now he
says
what uh what are you planning to do here
well dubo goes for rook c
captures uh rook c to e2 with check and
what do you play here magnus goes king
to h1 but king to h1 is already a
mistake
incredible but i mean uh this is such a
such a crazy
line in this opening that every move
seems to be a mistake so king to h2 is
what you have to play here
and you'll very soon see why magnus
played king to h1
and now feel free to pause the video and
try to find a
very crushing idea for duba while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting yet
another bishop captures an h3
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is uh in fact
that so bishop captures an h3 this was
played by duboff
and now if you don't capture it it is
just a free pawn so
you kind of have to do it g captures was
played and now comes
knight captures on b3 uh grabbing that
bishop here of course you cannot capture
the bishop because then queen to d5
check just wins you're going to pick up
this knight so
after knight captures on b3 queen
captures on e2 by magnus now guarding
the knight
and still queen to d5 with check we have
king to h2
and now dubo goes for uh knight captures
on a1
if double wanted he could have gone for
this very tricky knights to d4
and force an end game attack the queen
and wherever the queen goes doesn't
really matter you can even
offer a trade just queen captures an e5
with check temporary queen sacrifice and
then another royal fork captures king
moves and then you uh recapture the
queen
and you play the sand game bishop
against uh knight where
dubo would be up upon and he would have
a slightly better pawn structure
but he doesn't want to try this in a
blizz game against magnus so he goes for
material
knight captures on a1 bishop to b2 by
magnus is going to be a bit dangerous
now as magnus
will get a nice attack going and now
rook
8 e8 this was also a very good
opportunity to go for something like f6
then i'm down that uh
a light square bishop but it's it's an
ugly move to play
so dubo instead goes for rook a to e8
and now comes
rook to g1 so already you can see that
a lot of fun will happen here on this
square so magnus now prevents it
and now uh queen to g4 that's why it was
better to play it then because now it
it doesn't really do anything uh yes the
knight cannot move but queen g4 comes
with tempo with the threat of checkmate
so g5 by dubo the absolute strongest
move in the position even though it
looks ugly and now queen to f5 magnus is
trying to wiggle his way in with the
queen
uh and here we have rook to e7 duval
tries to create some sort of a barrier
here so the queen cannot deliver any
perpetuals or checkmating threats
but when in fact the rook captures on e5
was the way to go you have to trade
everything here on e5
and then it's just a nice draw rather
white cannot even capture and allow the
trade because
black is up material so white would have
to go for a nice perpetual here and we
would get a draw
but after queen f5 dubo uh probably
thinking that he was still on the attack
uh went for rook to e7 and now he gives
magnus a very very
uh well a very sneaky idea knight to g6
now both of the rooks are under attack
and it also seems like magnus overlooked
his queen
but in fact if queen captures uh knight
captures with
check now magnus with a royal fork king
f7 knight captures on f5
and now white is just completely winning
as white is up a piece
so here after knight g6 dubois tries
queen to d6
check but now rook the g3 blocking we
have knight captures on c2 by ma
by uh dubo and now knight captures an f8
magnus grabs the material here and now
uh
knight the d4 is a is a move that uh
uh duboff played which just uh uh
not all that great uh but it's very
tricky to find a move here and both of
them were below a minute
so here you have to go for knife to e3
it looks ugly but it's the only way for
black to continue the game
the rook cannot move so you can only
capture with the pawn but capturing with
the pawn
isn't all that great so here white would
have to struggle to find some sort of a
useful move probably queen to c8 to
threaten some discoveries
point is if the knight is captured then
rook captures with
now a double attack on the rook queen g6
check
king captures and now queen captures you
have to trade everything off
queen captures bishop captures and you
get this end game where
uh black uh has to avoid the trade he's
down a piece but
maybe maybe he can fight his being up
two pawns but it's very unlikely
uh however here after knight captures an
f8 duval played knight
to d4 instead and now comes bishop
captures on the four
queen captures and knight the e6 now not
allowing the rook to go down
uh and the queen is covering the f2 pawn
so that's not a problem
so here we have queen to e5 offering a
queen trade but now magnus goes in for
the kill
uh queen to g6 check king to h8 we have
queen capture sun h8 king to g8
uh and if you block with the rook then
of course queen to f8 is checkmate
so here after queen to h6 came to g8 was
played but now
uh queen to f8 check was played and it
was in this position unmoved 28 that uh
daniel dubo resigned the game and the
first game of the
tie breaks goes to magnus so we'll see
we'll see what happens
uh will magnus eliminate or will double
once again
uh eliminate magnus from the competition
uh so yeah here we resign because after
the key moves you just captured the rook
and then it's
gonna be a very quick checkmate so not
much to hope for here
uh yeah after king uh queen to f8 check
dubo resigned and now dubo has only one
more game to get back into the match to
force armageddon otherwise it's magnus
to the semi-finals and it's uh
well we're gonna continue the song some
other time uh
for for daniel lubov uh so yeah uh
that's uh that's it for for the game
thank you for watching uh i would like
to thank
narashman ragavan tito reynaldo justin
pollard david kimber and jacob argosino
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of this very nice tournament checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day